[Music]
good morning
how are you it's been great hasn't it
it's been i've been blown away by the
whole thing in fact i'm leaving
um there have been three themes haven't
they running through the conference
uh which are rather relevant to what i
want to talk about one is the
extraordinary evidence of human
creativity
in all of the presentations that we've
had and and in all the people here
just the variety of it and the range of
it
the second is that it's put us in a
place where we have no idea what's going
to happen
uh in terms of future no idea how this
may play out
i have an interest in education uh
actually what i find is
everybody has an interest in education
don't you
i find this very interesting if you're
at a dinner party and you say you work
in education
actually you're not often at dinner
parties frankly
if you work in education you're not
asked you know and uh
and you'll never ask back curiously
that's a thing that's straight to me
but if you are and you say to somebody
uh they say what do you do
and you say you work in education you
can see the blood run from their face
they think oh my god you know why me
it's my one night out all week
um but if you ask
about their education they pin you to
the wall because it's one of those
things that goes deep with people
am i right like religion and money
uh and other things so um
i have a big interest in education and i
think we all do we have a huge vested
interest in it
partly because it's education that's
meant to take us into this future that
we can't grasp
if you think of it children starting
school this year
will be retiring in 2065.
nobody has a clue despite all the
expertise that's been on parade for the
past four days
what the world will look like in five
years time and yet we're meant to be
educating them for it
so the unpredictability i think is
extraordinary and the third part of this
is that we've all agreed nonetheless
on the really um extraordinary
capacities that children have
their capacities for innovation i mean
serena last night was a marvel
wasn't she just seeing what she could do
and
she's exceptional but i think she's not
um
so to speak exceptional in the whole of
of childhood
what you have there is a person of
extraordinary dedication who found a
talent
and my contention is all kids have
tremendous talents and we squander them
pretty ruthlessly so i want to talk
about education
and i want to talk about creativity my
contention is that creativity now
is as important in education as literacy
and we should treat it with the same
status
thank you
[Music]
that was it by the way thank you very
much
[Laughter]
so 15 minutes left
well i was born no the um
i had a great story recently uh i love
telling it of a little girl
who was in a drawing lesson she was six
and she was at the back drawing and the
teacher said this little girl had ever
paid attention
and in this drawing lesson she did and
the teacher was fascinated she went over
to and she said
what are you drawing and the girl said
i'm drawing a picture of god
and the teacher said but nobody knows
what god looks like
and the girl said they will in a minute
okay when
when my son was four in england actually
he was four everywhere to be honest i
mean
apparently for being strict about it
wherever he went he was for that yeah
but
he was in the nativity play do you
remember the story
no it's big it's a big story mel gibson
to the sequel you may have seen it
nativity too but um
james got the part of joseph which we
were thrilled about we consider this to
be one of the lead parts
uh we had the place crammed full of
agents and t-shirts you know james
robinson is joseph
we had he didn't have to speak but the
other bit where the three kings come in
now they come in bearing gifts and they
bring gold frankincense and mayo this
really happened we were sitting there
and they
i think just went out of sequence
because we talked a little boy
afterwards and said you know
are you okay with that they said yeah
why was that wrong they just switched i
think that was it anyway the three boys
came in
little four-year-olds with tea towels on
their heads and they put these boxes
down the first boy said
i bring you gold and the second boy said
i bring you mare
and the third boy said frank sent this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what these things have in common is that
kids will take a chance
if they don't know they'll have a go
am i right they're not frightened of
being wrong
now i don't mean to say that being wrong
is the same thing as being creative
what we do know is if you're not
prepared to be wrong
you'll never come up with anything
original if you're not prepared
to be wrong and by the time they get to
be adults most kids have lost that
capacity
they have become frightened of being
wrong and we run our companies this by
the way we stigmatize mistakes
and we're now running national education
systems where mistakes
are the worst thing you can make and the
result is that we are
educating people out of their creative
capacities
picasso once said this he said that all
children are born
artists the problem is to remain an
artist as we grow up
i believe this passionately that we
don't grow into creativity
we grow out of it or rather we get
educated out of it
so why is this um i lived in stratford
haven
until about five years ago in fact we
moved from stratfor to los angeles
so you can imagine what a seamless
transition you know this was from
uh actually we lived in a place called
sinister field uh just outside stratford
which is where shakespeare's father was
born
are you struck by a new thought i was
you don't think of shakespeare having a
father do you
do you because you don't think of
shakespeare being a child
dude shakespeare being seven i never
thought of it
i mean he was a seven at some point he
was in somebody's english class wasn't
he
really how annoying would that be
[Laughter]
must try harder
being sent to bed by us now go to
shakespeare go to bed now you know to
william shakespeare
and put the pencil down and stop
speaking like that
you know it's it's
it's confusing everybody
anyway um
we moved from stratfor to los angeles
and i just want to
say what about the transition actually
my son didn't want to come i've got two
kids uh he's 21 now and my daughter's
16. he didn't want to come
to los angeles he loved it but he had a
girlfriend in england
uh this was the love of his life
sarah he'd known her for a month
mind you they've had their fourth
anniversary
because it's a long time when you're 16.
anyway he was really upset on the plane
he said i'll never find another girl
like sarah
and we were rather pleased about that
frankly because
she was
she was she was the main reason we're
leaving the country
but something strikes you when you move
to america and when you travel around
the world
every education system on earth has the
same hierarchy of subjects
everyone doesn't matter where you go you
think it would be otherwise but it isn't
at the top are mathematics and languages
then the humanity is in the bottom of
the arts everywhere on earth
and in pretty much every system too
there's
a hierarchy within the arts art and
music are normally given a higher status
in schools than drama and dance
there isn't an education system on the
planet that teaches dance every day to
children the way we teach the
mathematics
why why not i think this is rather
important
i think maths is very important but so
is dance children dance all the time if
they're allowed to we all do
we all have bodies don't we yeah did i
miss a meeting i mean
i think
truthfully what happens is as children
grow up we start to educate them
progressively from the waist up
and then we focus on their heads and
slightly to one side
if you were to visit education as an
alien and say what's it for
public education i think you'd have to
conclude if you look at the output you
know who really succeeds by this who
does everything they should
who gets all the brownie points you know
who are the winners i think you'd have
to conclude the whole purpose of public
education throughout the world
is to produce university professors
isn't it they're the people who come out
the top and i used to be one
so there you know
but and i like university professors but
you know
we shouldn't hold them up as the uh the
high water mark of all human achievement
they're just a form of life
you know another form of life but
they're rather curious and i say this
out of affection for them
there's somebody curious about
professors in my experience not all of
them but typically
they live in their heads they live up
there
and slightly to one side they're
disembodied
you know in a kind of literal way you
know they they look upon their body as a
form of transport for their heads
you know it's
don't they it's a way of getting their
head to meetings
if you want real evidence of out-of-body
experiences by the way
get yourself along to a residential
conference for senior academics
and pop into the discotheque on the
final night
and there you will see it grown men and
women writhing uncontrollably
off the beat
waiting to end so go and write a paper
about it now
our education system is predicated on
the idea of academic ability
and there's a reason the whole system
was invented around the world there were
no public systems of education really
before the 19th century
they all came into being to meet the
needs of industrialism
so the hierarchy is rooted on two ideas
number one
that the the most useful subjects for
work are at the top
so you were probably stayed benignly
away from things at school when you're a
kid
things you liked on the ground you would
never get a job doing that
is that right don't do music you're not
going to be a musician don't do art you
won't be an artist
uh benign advice now profoundly mistaken
the whole world is engulfed in a
revolution and the second is
academic ability which has really come
to dominate our view of intelligence
because the
universities designed the system in
their image if you think about the whole
system of public education around the
world
it's a protracted process of university
entrance and the consequences that many
highly talented
brilliant creative people think they're
not
because the thing they were good at at
school wasn't valued or was actually
stigmatized
and i think we can't afford to go on
that way in the next 30 years
according to unesco more people
worldwide will be graduating through
education than since the beginning of
history
more people and it's the combination of
all the things we've talked about
technology and its transformation effect
on work
and demography and the huge explosion in
population
suddenly degrees aren't worth anything
isn't that true
when i was a student if you had a degree
you had a job if you didn't have a job
it's because you didn't want one
and i didn't want one frankly so um
but now kids without with degrees are
often heading home uh to carry on
playing video games
because you need an ma where the
previous job required a ba and now you
need a phd for the other
it's a process of academic inflation and
it indicates the whole structure of
education is shifting beneath
our feet we need to radically rethink
our view of intelligence
we know three things about intelligence
one it's diverse
we think about the world in all the ways
that we experience it we think visually
we think in sound we think
kinesthetically
we think in abstract terms we think in
movement
secondly intelligence is dynamic
if you look at the interactions of a
human brain as we heard yesterday from
a number of presentations intelligence
is wonderfully interactive
the brain isn't divided into
compartments in fact
creativity which i define as the process
of having original ideas that have value
more often than not comes about through
the interaction
of different disciplinary ways of seeing
things
the brain is intensely by the way
there's a shaft of nerves that joins the
two halves of the brain called the
corpus callosum it's thicker in women
following on from helen yesterday i
think this is probably why women are
better at multitasking
because you are aren't you that's a raft
of research
but i know for my personal life if my
wife is cooking a meal at home
which is not often thankfully but you
know if she's saying
she's no she's good at some things but
if she's cooking
you know she's dealing with people on
the phone she's talking to the kids
she's painting the ceiling you know
she's
doing open-heart surgery over here if
i'm cooking the door is shut
the kids are out the phone's on the hook
if she comes in i get annoyed
i say terry please i'm trying to fry an
egg in here you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
give me a break
actually there was a during that old
philosophical thing if a tree falls in a
in a forest and nobody hears it did it
happen
remember that old chestnut i saw a great
t-shirt really recently which said
um if a man speaks his mind in a forest
and no woman hears him
is he still wrong
[Laughter]
and the third thing about intelligence
is it's distinct
i i'm doing a new book at the moment
called epiphany which is uh based on a
series of interviews with people about
how they discovered their talent
i'm fascinated by how people got to be
there uh it's really prompted by a
conversation i had with a wonderful
woman who
most people have never heard of she's
called jillian lynn have you heard of
her
some have she's a choreographer and
everybody knows her work she did cats
and phantom of the opera she's wonderful
i used to be on the board of the royal
ballet in england
as you can see and uh
anyway julian i had lunch on that i said
how'd you get to be a dancer and she
said it was interesting when she was at
school she was really hopeless
and the school in the 30s wrote to her
parents said we think jillian has a
learning disorder
she couldn't concentrate she was
fidgeting i think now they'd say she had
adhd
wouldn't you but this was the 1930s an
adhd hadn't been invented you know at
this point so it
wasn't an available condition you know
people
people people weren't aware they could
have that
anyway she sent went to see this um this
specialist
so this oak panel room and she was there
with with her mother and she
was led and sat on this uh chair at the
end and she sat on her hands for 20
minutes while this man talked to mother
about all the problems jillian was
having at school
and at the end of it um because she was
disturbing people at home work was
always late and so a little kid of a
in the end uh the uh the doctor went and
sat next to him and said julian i've
listened to all these things that
mother's told me i need to speak to her
privately
so she said he said wait here we'll be
back we won't be very long and
and uh and they went and left it but as
they went out the room he turned on the
radio that was sitting on his desk
and when they got out the room he said
to mother just stand and watch her
and um the minute they left the room
she said she was on their feet moving to
the music and they watched a few minutes
and he turned to her mother
and he said you know mrs lin jillian
isn't sick
she's a dancer
take her to a dance school i said what
happened said she did
i can't tell you how wonderful it was we
walked in this room and it was full of
people like me
people who couldn't sit still people who
had to move
to think who had to move to think they
did ballet
they did tap they did jazz they did
modern contemporary she was eventually
auditioned for the royal ballet school
she became a soloist she had a wonderful
career at the royal ballet she
eventually graduated from the royal
ballet school
found her own company the julian dance
company met andrew lloyd webber
she's been responsible for some of the
successful musical theater productions
in history
she's given pleasure to millions and
she's a multi-millionaire
somebody else might have put on
medication and told her to calm down
now i think
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what i think it comes to is this al gore
spoke uh the other night about
ecology and the revolution that was
triggered by
rachel carson i believe our only hope
for the future
is to adopt a new conception of human
ecology
one in which we start to reconstitute
our conception of the richness of human
capacity our education system has
mined our minds in the way that we strip
mine the earth
for a particular commodity and for the
future it won't serve us
we have to rethink the fundamental
principles on which we're educating our
children
there was a wonderful quote by jonas
salk who said if you were to
uh if all the insects were to disappear
from the earth
within 50 years all life on earth would
end
if all human beings disappeared from the
earth
within 50 years all forms of life would
flourish
and he's right what ted celebrates
is the gift of the human imagination we
have to be
careful now that we use this gift wisely
and that we avert some of the scenarios
that we've talked about and the only way
we'll do it
is by seeing our creative capacities for
the richness they are
and seeing our children for the hope
that they are
and our task is to educate their whole
being so they can face this future by
the way
we may not see this future but they will
and our job is to help them make
something of it thank you very much
[Music]
what if great ideas weren't cherished
[Music]
what if they carried no importance
[Music]
or held no value
[Music]
there is a place where artistic vision
is protected where inspired design ideas
live on
to become ultimate driving machines